with each film with each chapter we get
to introduce another incredible Talent
Jason Momoa you all know him
but you will never ever forget Dante
Reyes I'm Dante I'm Shantae
[Applause]
I love motorcycles
I freaking love cars
then I'm like why wouldn't I want to be
a part of a car chase movie and be in
freaking Rome ride motorcycles
Rome I'm
about to learn all about fear
I hadn't played a villain in probably 10
years I really wanted to bring something
that hadn't been done yet face off
against Dom and his family he's been
done wrong in his mind he wouldn't have
any enemies in Rio would you
he has a son
you had to be a certain psychotic
it's like a peacock one of my character
be like a peacock
[Music]
dumb this time he's worried for his
family and worried for the world how do
you choose the ones you save he's made
his match his enemy is fluid he's a
snake we don't know where he's going
Dante is obsessed with them a little
embarrassed you saw my vision board
Dante has learned from them and he knows
everything about them collateral damage
chaos death I'm your legacy it's strange
to have an enemy who adores you stop
talking you face me the game's not over
yet the way that Jason portrays this
character Dante Reyes really plays
nicely into the mythology everyone dies
that was awesome he was so confident and
he just came in with this like lace
detailed open shirt that was like
flowing and the hair and the body I was
like just so an awe staring at him and
then I like catch myself I'm like oh my
God I'm in the scene I have to like act
right now did you notice how hot Momoa
is has anybody notice that or is that
just me you know
do my best
it's like being a kid in a candy shop
and you roll up on set and you see all
the cars and you see Dom's car and
you're like holy it's a charger
go on black look good the difference
between Dante and Jason is just the
cruelty but the rest is the same the
nail polish is the same that's Jason
Momoa it's exciting to be just a piece
in the puzzle of wrapping up something
that's so very important pop culture I
can't believe I'm gonna erase the great
Dominic Toretto didn't come true
never X dealt with
see you soon